It's been a long day, so
we got some food.
Very questionable logo. Yes, very.
We drove from Connecticut to New York at what,
6 a m. This morning?
Yeah. And it's currently 10 20.
Yeah. Let's wake up the baby.
Yeah.
I've been craving donut for so long,
and every time I'm in New York,
we get it. What did you get?
Oh, sorry.
It's okay. I got this box.
I got this. I got two boxes of French fries,
lettuces, onions.
Wait, hold on. Cabbages.
We got two spicy sauces, two white sauces.
I know lucky won't have the white ones,
but you'll have the spicy ones, right?
Lucky has an issue with anything creamy.
I don't know what it is. We've been so busy.
We're gonna be traveling all over,
so we won't be home for the next month.
So that's gonna be wild. I also.
I don't know how I feel about that.
Kind of excited, but also
I'll miss cooking at home cause we'll be doing so much eating out.
Yeah. Which I'm not excited about.
Okay, this is yours?
Oh, my.
Yes, it is.
You're gonna eat all of this?
Yep. You ordered two of these?
What? I love how you're talking,
but I like you're shocked and surprised.
Not really, but then I'm always surprised.
I also have something really exciting coming up.
I'm doing a pop up.
Lucky's actually gonna come support me.
Yes. Um,
I posted everything. Very supportive of you.
I'm gonna Post more updates on my Instagram stories
if you guys wanna come. If you don't,
I totally get it. Just come say hi.
I wanna hang. I wanna hang out.
Ooh, that's good.
Okay, this is what I got. It's basically bread.
It just looks funny on camera.
The orange soda, star of the show.
Here. I got the.
The donor. So,
chicken and beef,
red cabbage,
garlic sauce, lettuce,
tomato, and onion.
Also, my eczema has been so bad lately,
and then I wanted a juice box.
Oh, can I try some of your food?
Yes, you can.
You figure out the water?
Was that ice I heard? Yes.
Wow. Stunning.
I've just been snacking on your fries.
Any German words? You. You know,
I didn't think you. Of course.
Lucky always says the most random words,
thinking that they're okay.
Say one real German word that you actually know.
Danke schn. No.
Danke schn. Yeah,
danke schn.
Anything else you have to add? Peace,
love, and happiness for everyone.